[Musica]
innovazione fermiamoci un secondo su
questo termine Qual è la prima cosa che
vi viene in mente
Scommetto perché in realtà ho sottoposto
a una serie di incolpevoli amici questo
switch prima di voi tranquilli che molti
di voi abbiano pensato a una tecnologia
probabilmente anche con l'aiuto degli
speech prima una tecnologia un prodotto
un'invenzione che ha radicalmente
cambiato il nostro stile di vita
prendiamoci 5 secondi per dire alla
persona che ci sta accanto quello che
abbiamo pensato e un esercizio
interessante in realtà perché ci dà la
dimensione di come ciascuno di noi si
riferisca all'innovazione in modi
assolutamente diversi provare per
credere
senza entrare nel merito della
definizione che ciascuno di voi ha dato
tranquilli non vi interrogherò credo di
poter dire con una certa tranquillità
che la maggior parte di noi tende ad
associare l'innovazione a qualche cosa
che ha cambiato radicalmente il nostro
il nostro aspetto bene Ha un Nino
Diciamo ad una novità assoluta quello di
cui vorrei parlargli di oggi però non è
questo non è l'aspetto radicale
dell'Innovazione bensì il suo aspetto di
trasformazione parziale vorrei anzi
voglio contribuire all'operazione di
avvicinare il concetto di innovazione a
ciascuno di noi per condividere con voi
e in realtà un pensiero semplice ovvero
la mia convenzione che ciascuno di noi
in ambiti in contesti con tempi diversi
possa in realtà essere un innovatore
secondo una delle teorie
dell'Innovazione ciascuno di noi si pone
in maniera diversa nei confronti del
cambiamento vi sono diversi profili
senza entrare troppo nel merito
Ovviamente i tradizionalisti a chi non è
capitato di pensare lasciamo tutto
esattamente come oppure non so in
mantenitori che sono meno esplicitamente
contrarre l'innovazione ma comunque
fanno fatica a comprenderne quello che è
la portata Beh in realtà a me piace
riferirmi ad un altro profilo in cui mi
ci riconosco Per altro ok il profilo
degli adattatori e che trovo sia
estremamente connesso a chi vuole e può
avere un impatto piccolo grande che sia
Beh innanzitutto l'adattatore non è
necessariamente amante del cambiamento
però con responsabilità se ne fa carico
mette coraggio e cerca di intraprendere
dei percorsi di innovazione non solo fa
in modo che anche gli altri intrappano
gli stessi percorsi vi sono poi
ovviamente Avevo un ultimo profilo
quello degli innovatori vabbè design a
questo possiamo sicuramente riferire
alcune delle invenzioni che abbiamo
pensato prima o probabilmente
i personaggi che sono stati citati o
ancora le persone che sono passate su
questo puntino prima di me passeranno
dopo di me Comunque qualsiasi sia in
realtà il profilo in cui ciascuno di voi
si riconosce credo che possiate
convenire con me che in un mondo fatto
di complessità ambiguità incertezza
evolvere ovvero innovare e quanto più
indispensabile e rendersi disponibili al
cambiamento e in realtà Un'operazione
che forse ci consente di vivere anche un
pochettino più serenamente Ma come
possiamo renderci disponibili al
cambiamento non solo fare un'operazione
in più come possiamo essere portatori di
cambiamento Beh ci aiuta la
considerazione e la consapevolezza che
l'innovazione può essere definita
secondo il suo grado di intensità non
esiste in realtà solo l'innovazione
radicale se noi guardiamo banalmente ai
sinonimi della parola innovazione
possiamo trovare parole come evoluzione
rivoluzione e modernizzazione al tempo
stesso Beh questo ci suggerisce una
dimensione incrementale dell'Innovazione
una un innovazione che adatta a portare
una trasformazione e ad individuare
soluzioni a qualche cosa di già
esistente e un insieme di processi che
vogliono portare il miglioramento a
qualcosa che esiste già
per farvi un esempio molto concreto oggi
noi qui siamo dentro un'innovazione
incrementale Ebbene sì perché portare un
Ted al di fuori del suo contesto
tradizionale specifico del suo setting è
stato un innovazione un innovazione
peraltro dettata da una necessità
specifica perché spesso e volentieri
l'innovazione incrementale non è l'idea
bensì è una soluzione ad un problema ad
una necessità esistente quindi se
partiamo dal presupposto che esiste
un'innovazione che non è radicale ma è
incrementale credo si possa dire che non
è necessario essere degli Inventori per
essere degli innovatori e questo per
persone normali assolutamente come me
penso sia una buona notizia
obiettivamente ma non dobbiamo al
contempo fare un errore ovvero quello di
pensare che l'introduzione di
innovazione seppur incrementale sia
un'operazione semplice l'innovazione
incrementale è comunque una
trasformazione seppur ridotta quindi
come tale e adatta a portare un
cambiamento ad uno status quo Questo
significa che molto probabilmente
troverà delle barriere e poche risorse
il contesto è quindi fondamentale per
portare innovazione dobbiamo conoscere
il contesto che ovviamente più sarà
conservativo più ci renderà difficile
obiettivamente la vita e se ci pensate
questo è vero sia da un punto di vista
professionale che personale noi se
consideriamo l'innovazione Come
un'attitudine possiamo essere
consapevoli del fatto che si può
apportare il cambiamento al di fuori di
noi e dentro di noi in un contesto
aziendale in un contesto professionale
Non si può introdurre innovazione Se
questa non è condivisa e se non c'è in
Dortmund l'innovazione non si può
imporre e non si può neanche
semplicemente proporre in realtà
l'innovazione richiede un cambiamento
culturale delle persone che la
sostengono
l'innovazione richiede dei modelli
organizzativi che ne consentano
l'implementazione che diano spazio alle
idee alle giuste idee che possono
apportare un miglioramento vi faccio un
esempio vi racconto una storia
un anno fa il mio ruolo non era quello
del rinnovation manager A dire il vero
l'innovation manager il ruolo delle
Innovation manager proprio non esisteva
Sì mi ero occupata ho fatto sviluppo di
business di brand di attività fini ma
innovazioni intesa come appunto processo
come materia come disciplina non
rientrava nel mio vocabolario e
tantomeno nel mio ruolo poi un giorno su
input del Management ho avuto
l'opportunità di trovarmi intorno ad un
tavolo per discutere del concetto di
innovazione La domanda era Che cosa
significa innovazione un po'
l'operazione che abbiamo fatto noi tutti
insieme prima e che cosa l'innovazione
potesse significare in quello specifico
contesto intorno a quel tavolo con me un
gruppo una squadra dei colleghi che
hanno portato le loro prospettive le
loro esperienze ma soprattutto il loro
metodo di analisi profondamente diverso
e proprio quella diversità proprio quel
tavolo Ha portato dei progetti che oggi
mi consentono di lavorare
all'innovazione in modalità in modo
professionale e soprattutto mi
consentono di essere qui oggi su questo
puntino rosso
consapevole di una serie di cose
fondamentali l'importanza di quella
discussione l'importanza di aver
dedicato del tempo che non era dovuto
del tempo che andava oltre le nostre
mansioni quotidiane ad un'operazione di
proposizione e soprattutto L'importanza
di un contesto che ci ha consentito di
fare questo tipo di operazione un
contesto che ha in qualche modo
supportato Un'operazione che potremmo
definire di
imprenditorialità interna Che cosa
significa significa semplicemente
consentire alle idee che sono volte a
portare un'innovazione di crescere e di
nascere e di vedere la luce
un anno fa non esisteva un progetto
aziendalmente condiviso di innovazione e
questo è stato un innovazione tormentale
sia per il contesto professionale sia
per la mia personalissima esperienza
personale Beh forse vi starete chiedendo
ma esattamente un Innovation manager
peraltro di una squadra di calcio che
cosa fa Beh un Innovation manager per
come lo vedo io connette i puntini che
in realtà era la definizione di
creatività che è un grande innovatore
daba un Innovation manager un
facilitatore qualcuno che ha la
possibilità e il tempo questa cosa
preziosa per andare al di fuori del Day
by day del quotidiano e guardare al di
là per Una sbirciatina al futuro
interloquire parlare con realtà
innovative cercare di trovare delle
soluzioni a delle necessità che ci sono
che esistono ma che tante volte non si
riescono a seguire perché siamo troppo
impegnati Nel portare avanti i nostri
compiti quotidiani
Non so per farvi degli esempi sono
passata da
innovative tecnologie di allenamento
cognitivo a piattaforme educative sono
passata dall'intelligenza artificiale
per arrivare a dei concorsi di idee
rivolte ai giovani tutto sempre con un
solo unico obiettivo quello di tradurre
in valore delle idee delle opportunità e
di cercare di allinearle Ovviamente con
una strategia e con degli obiettivi
aziendali bene
considerate per altro che la figura del
manager dell'Innovazione non è nuova
soltanto nelle Industrie calcistica dove
peraltro oggi nel contesto e nel
panorama italiano questo rappresenta un
unico Progetto Unico ma lo è nel
panorama complessivo delle aziende di in
Italia peraltro solo il 9% dei profili
al femminile a proposito di innovazione
comunque se qualcuno un anno fa mi
avesse detto che oggi mi sarei ritrovata
su questo palco io personalmente non ci
avrei creduto
e se può sembrare può essere sembrata
dal mio racconto un'operazione facile
diciamo un cambiamento lineare Beh no
assolutamente non è stato così è stato
un complesso percorso da un punto di
vista personale di cambiamento che
fatica uscire dalla comfort zone di un
ruolo che avevo ricoperto per tanto
tempo immaginatevi il momento in cui ti
hanno detto sì puoi fare una cosa
fichissima Ma devi lasciare tutto quello
che hai fatto fino a ieri le persone
meravigliose comprese che ti hanno
accompagnato in questo viaggio Beh in
alcuni momenti ho fatto fatica a vedere
Effettivamente quello che fosse il
cambiamento Ma poi pian piano una zona
di comfort che si amplia nuovi confini
nuove opportunità persone meravigliose
persone nuove ed un contesto
meraviglioso quello dell'Innovazione mi
hanno portato a un cambiamento costante
quotidiano e composto dove per composto
non intendo come diciamo mia nonna
seduta bene a tavola Ma intendo quella
accezione della matematica finanziaria
secondo cui se noi quotidianamente
reinvestiamo
possiamo ottenere dei risultati
esponenziali bene questa per me
personalmente è la meraviglia
dell'Innovazione incrementale e
l'opportunità che ciascuno di noi ha di
avere un impatto Piccolo o grande che
sia e raggiungere dei risultati
straordinari quando obiettivamente erano
assolutamente insperati ma semplicemente
inimmaginabili e alzare la mano e
discutere con un collega e cercare di
portare avanti delle idee di cui siamo
convinti e che pensiamo che possano
portare un miglioramento bene questa è
vera innovazione per me questa è
l'innovazione alla portata di ciascuno
di noi e l'innovazione condivisa
l'innovazione incrementale e in questo
il calcio è maestro se non c'è Squadra
non si può né vincere né innovare e noi
possiamo essere degli innovatori una
grande squadra
[Applauso]